[Music]  I stand before you again tonight  after almost two terms as your president  to tell you I am more optimistic about  the future of America than ever the boat  I know is full of courage and optimism  and ingenuity the America I know is  decent and generous  [Music]  folks with disabilities  under the same crowd  country that we love  [Applause]  declarations  papers right here in Philadelphia all  those years ago three  these truths to be self-evident that all  form a more perfect union  [Applause]  [Music]  always fail in the end  it's been you who few over mine  were great even  Oh in the face of difficulty  put in the face of uncertainty The  Audacity of Hope  these past eight years  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  Oh jerk  let's keep it going god bless you  god bless the United States of America  you  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]